hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bear simulator the game
where you can be the best bear that you
ever wanted to be and hopefully live out
your life and find salmon and hibernate
a long time and then attack an
oscar-winning actor when he's lost in
the woods as a fur trapper
that's a topical oh my goodness am i
standing on my hind legs oh this is
amazing
oh this is incredible I I honestly don't
know oh right I got an achievement I am
do bear
I am bear I am Baron I am swipe Klaus
what is that over there
oh hello common grub yes please
I snapped on the common grub wow there's
nothing like goat simulator this is
actually honestly truly me as a bear and
it's pretty incredible oh it's so
delightful food yay oh is that a Paul or
is that berry red apple nevermind I was
wrong on both accounts this is
legitimately just a bear simulator uh I
have a feeling that things are gonna go
weird ah the noble bear stalks his prey
the common pond duck let me get down and
crawl poison you'll never see me coming
you'll never know ah I had you I was
gonna swoop at you don't soif away oh I
lost my one chance to make a waterfowl
friend okay a mark left by it I thought
that said goober at first never mind
ability smell one required well how do I
get smell one oh that's how I could
smell 100 duck dip dive dodge and duck
oh my goodness how do I get Wow
I need intelligence of eleven is that
what a Wow oh my god it's legitimately
bear simulator this is incredible reach
for the skies how do I do that oh okay
apparently bears I uh
this has got to be the dopiest looking
bear just walking on his hind legs with
paws outstretched but you know what
I'm not gonna question it because after
all oh hello
I didn't know that I was going for a
dive it's not giving me a lot of
instructions I mean I can only ponder
that I need to do what bears do which is
fine food find a mate Maul someone in
the woods and then snatch picnic baskets
put out forest fires I honestly don't
know how it bears tube in the woods
besides poop and I'm pretty sure this
game wouldn't have me poop everywhere
would it hello
25 intelligence needed to eat I'm too
stupid I'm too stupid to eat this well I
can't fit my jaws around it's just too
too much for my mortal mind to
comprehend
oh my poor bareness what is this what
even maybe it's too stupid well I mean
if I was stupid I would eat the things
you're coming from night ahh
Oh Oh who's what now I defeated the
dreadful pawn duck ha ha ha I gained
your swim powers apparently I don't know
how that works
are you a bun bun bun bun got add I died
get ready you better run run you better
run oh you better run run bun bun yeah
yeah I'm trying too bad at you ha ha ha
tan rabbit has been defeated defeated
the demoralizing Dan rabbit what did he
insult me as he went along I'm no
tortoise ain't gonna give me oh I just
ate them all in one gulp
this game is literally not figuratively
not silly-billy like a lot of other
simulator games this is legitimately
like gyro bear simulator right here
there's been an odd number of requests
for me to play Euro Truck Simulator and
frankly I don't want to spend 12 hours
driving a truck all the way across
Europe hello hmm
do I get to devour some humans some
humans their intrusion oh hello
Oh another bun bun is he gonna get away
no he's not it's definitely not
oh those sound effects well sorry buddy
but uh the faster apparently is a bear
and I'm going to win
I got a claw upgrade cool oh wow it
looks so much different than the last
one I can only assume into the flicks
twice more dim someone just left a
veggie pizzas a new higher bond oh this
is very fortunate for a bear I hit a
couple slices of pizza oh okay well this
makes life a lot easier if I just steal
bear cub spotted in area no signs of
larger bears is present be cautious and
do not travel alone I'll keep that in
mind I'll let my other bear friend know
there's a missing bear baby
hello I'm undone you better keep keep
your hand right where I can see them
cuz I'm keeping mine right up by my face
tonight murder is the intent and whoa
hey hey come here you come here hey hey
hey come on hey come on let's not be
ridiculous here
friggin can you can you not you bill bun
bastard where'd you go oh you're stuck
by the river oh that was just sad that
it was a fight right up until that point
when he realized that he couldn't swim
police warning recent reports of
unidentified people or large animals
sighted here please use caution report
any suspicious behavior to three well uh
did someone draw boobs or eyeballs
they're remarkably similar
Jax party house jack god damn and I'm
trying to have a good time here being a
bear stop partying open everyone no
fishing from the structure no alcohol
will suck it no open fires of barbecues
and no firearms or dangerous weapons I'm
bringing my cat please King up Woon
leaving oh I don't want to kill a cat
what's that in there I don't want to
murder a cat Oh No
yeah did someone leave another pizza out
here oh my goodness they did hello
cheese pizza was that say huh uh what I
learned in boating school is
oh that's reference to SpongeBob correct
so depop thick and chunky just what you
want from a gravy soda ah mix beverage
it's just what the kids put out like you
know that game you play when you put
everything on the table into one drink I
lost my Rastafarian hat how am I
supposed to jam now if anyone finds it
call me I think I lost it at the beach
oh I'll help you out on that one mark
left by a pig are you sure are you sure
are you a hundred percent sure are you
just being insulting to all humans all
right couple slices of pizza more gravy
soda for no particular reason and what
else
Oh a hot top yes
too bad you can't enjoy a baseball game
without freaking everybody out oh okay I
think this game is getting a little more
to kill us now oh no I'm so adorable oh
my goodness I am bestbear you have app
come back here I want to get you I need
your water fowl in my belly is gonna say
but that'd be a little weird never mind
oh what's this it's a dry grub you give
me intelligence do I get a nose upgrade
yes I get another ability
oh how do I get down there do i smash
through hey yeah okay I don't know how
to get in there but I found a dry grub
and I do have smell one so if I wanted
to I could go back is that gravy soda oh
yeah it's gravy soda great got the mixed
beverage of deliciousness
I'm gonna go see what's in that weird
complex over there oh no public stay out
NP no problem come here ha ha chicken
butt ah
why was there just a chicken sitting
around here girl ate it up please these
don't give me intelligence but there's
gotta be something else around here
hello is this how are you why
their dead body around here is there
flies hanging around a corpse that I
should be worried about how am I gonna
be implicated for bear murder I mean I
swear I didn't know leo who's just
trying to film a movie in my woods I was
just trying to help I was giving him a
big encouragement hug about those Oscars
yeah yeah okay all right think I spot
another grub over here
oh no that's a marking I don't know if I
can smell that one damn it
smell to my smeller just ain't good
enough hello tee-hanks Oil Co I don't
know what that what is I don't a thermos
absolutely oh there's a okay I guess
we're moving on I don't know okay oh
there's a lot of smells around here
smells that I won't be able to smell how
old I be able to do anything that's why
an alligator
please come below the platform for a
special guest dinner you're invited Ali
Ali Ali alligator alligator oh okay oh
by a gopher terrible about that dinner
invitation friends I believe the
alligators a foul intentions go for Mary
okay oh man where were people just
rubbing their asses all over this to
spread messages guys I was invited to
dinner by alligators I think they
welcomed me as one of their own great
spelling they're Donald Duck you're
doing fantastically hello we're gonna
fight oh oh oh oh oh I didn't know if I
was supposed to fight you I did how was
I supposed to know I've killed
everything up into this point
wow you are murdering me we'll all my
goodness ha ha
why is my right hand not hitting aah
close one no I was out him am i dead I
was dude aah I got knocked out but a
mysterious force wreckage good me I'm
back at Maidan this ball I had that my
right hand wasn't connecting this is a
load of bull zero out of ten on this
bear accuracy for its swiping mechanics
it's a load of crap and I would know I'm
a bear I produce
Oh's okay ah gotcha it's y-q right yeah
let's go whoa hello hi uh bro I don't
want to mess with you but I'm just gonna
eat you up okay you stay there though
okay goodbye sir
be careful friends I think a bear lives
here hey I don't take too kindly to that
go for Mary oh okay I guess we're gonna
upgrade my bear bed
to get bear better bear night to sleep
cuz the one thing my bear worries about
is his lumbar support when he's sleeping
he needs a he's a huh tempur-pedic
mattress so he kids a Big Sleep
shut up everybody I'm try I spent the
weekend with Wade the puns are coming no
matter what hello ru you're nothing I
should just move on because there's a
brand new area with lies actually
honestly it's delightful in rather
gorgeous but I'm wondering if there oh
hello is this bear the militant Mary
gopher am I about to storm the gates of
it or maybe there's another dead or
something I mean that seems like a
zombie apocalypse type barrier or
something for a river maybe there's a
dry riverbed
oh hello who are you what is going on oh
my god that's gorgeous except it's not
oh wow
civilization is legitimately like a
standoff it's for a war excuse me I'm
just gonna go around the barricades
Barry effect
AHA barricades get in ha ha there better
be something very watch out for wolf
boys they cray well I'm just gonna take
a few minutes to process the
understanding of that what is this
that's stamen there which was totally
bonkers hi how's it going
no trespassing top-secret military
research compound use of deadly force
well good job telling everybody there's
a top-secret compound at least you're
gonna kill them before they actually get
away with that knowledge smell be
careful friends this whole area omits a
bad or odd really it's the menacing fog
slash dust storm called dust valley well
I was right on the nose
that one my keen bear sense is getting
to me ooh can I read this nope wolf boys
wow so the wolf boys do the wolf boys
walk on their hind legs and shoot guns
at my face because that would be the
only threatening thing here oh hello
hi oh it's a wolf boy he's rabid he
looks like a Corgi
oh God oh ah he's too time run run
well I got one else oh sorry wolf boy I
wasn't ready for you oh my god
no oh some tells me I shouldn't have
done that well I got knocked out but a
mysterious force rescued me well I think
that's it in this video
this is oddly fun like it takes itself
just seriously enough to be a reputable
bear simulator which is what I've always
wanted out of a gaming experience but
yet it has the delightful
lightheartedness of a true experience of
bareness that I believe all pairs have
so that's all I'm gonna do for now
little even has weather simulation how
incredible this game has it all so thank
you everybody so much for watching you
can find this game on Steam uh I really
have nothing else to say about it so say
words for me let me know what you think
of it came in the comments below and
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye Oh
okay big balls big blue balls priority
alert one big blue ball alert